spring in Matt Ryan the falcons
quarterback congrats on the win in
Oakland Matt thanks for joining us this
morning yeah happy to be on down what do
you remember about the scouts the
negative things they said about you oh
man is they kind of find everything you
know for me one of the big knocks many
interceptions I guess my senior year and
and all that kind of stuff and and you
know in terms of arm strength all those
kind of things they could take
everything and to me you know like you
guys mentioned I think the most
important thing that's often overlooked
is accuracy right it doesn't matter how
it comes out or whatever motion sighs
all that kind of stuff it's about
whether or not you can put the ball in
the right place at the right time and to
me that's the most important thing
Paulie do you have matts draft profile
yeah from NFL com do you want the good
of the bad Matt are you okay with the
good in the back yeah you cannot hurt at
all it's all good okay all right go
ahead pull lacks the arm strength to
challenge deep secondary I cannot run
much at all has actually said okay those
others had good some some how you
overcame that to become the third pick
in the draft could you explain to
somebody how difficult it is to play
quarterback in the NFL if they had never
seen if you were describing your job
what would your job description be well
I it you know you have to have great
vision and so you have to be able to see
things in like basically in the amount
of time it takes you to blink your eye
you have to be able to process
information you know understand where
you need to go with the football and
then physically be able to do it you
know put it where you want to be able to
put it in the right spot at the right
time just that part's difficult and you
know not to mention all the other stuff
that goes along with playing this
position in this league at this time
it's it's a you know it's as popular as
ever and probably is scrutinized as ever
what about your personality in what you
show to your teammates we were talking
about Jay Cutler and
look I don't want this you to be
involved in Jay Cutler bashing but the
personality that you show that you care
you're angry you're excited how will
where are you during the game of how you
look well i think you know body language
is so important and and you know your
teammate speed awesome that's one of the
things about playing quarterback and
leadership is that you know part of play
in this position is all of those things
that go along with it and for me you
know I'm always conscious of you know my
body language and you know my poise and
just trying to stay calm and be a
calming influence for everybody around
you because things are crazy out there
and you know I want those guys to come
in the huddle and look at a guy that you
know is going to solve the problem for
us and that's what I always try and
focus on do you ever get mad almost as a
demonstration just so they see you're
getting mad like just change it up so
they don't you know sometimes an umpire
or a manager will get thrown out of a
game just to say to his team I'm
fighting for you even though he doesn't
want to really get thrown out of the
game yeah there's usually enough stuff
that goes on out there that i'm actually
genuinely tell me that that's that's
that's not that difficult I think
sometimes it from the other end where
you have to you know rain back and and
not let it go too much do you work the
officials yeah you know I think you have
to at the quarterback position just with
the way the rules are you know anytime I
get contacted you know below the waist
or above the shoulders you know I think
you're doing your team a disservice if
you don't try and lobby for those calls
because you know that's part of the
rules and and you know so I definitely
do does that hockey Lee have better arms
than you yes he does I think you stated
a lot more time on it too he works hard
yeah he you know every time I see him
I'm always impressed he's a matt ryan
the falcons quarterback joining
Stan Patrick show if you owned a team
right now today and we're gonna do a
draft later and you have to take a
quarterback now for the next seven years
you can't take yourself who are you
taking ooh tough stick I mean that's uh
that's a good question I heard you guys
talking about Carson Wentz right before
I got on obviously he's had a great
start to it Andrew Luck to me is a guy
that's extremely talented young can do
everything I know are you stalling
you're strolling right guys I would
think about your still exactly snow so
I'm just throwing out every day Mike a
good young player but you're not taking
Brady you're not taking breeze later
because of their age but if you're
taking these young quarterback and we're
trying to figure this out I don't know
if Jack Prescott is good I don't know if
Carson wins is good but what should we
be looking for with these young
quarterbacks that you think will
probably guarantee or at least given
give them a hope at long-term success
well I think the number one thing is is
there's two things to me it's it's about
you know making plays on third downs to
keep drives going and then obviously you
know scoring situation plays to me those
are critical at the quarterback position
and so I think both those guys I mean I
saw a little bit of last night I haven't
seen dak Plei yet but I saw a little bit
of last night Carson in in the Monday
night game I got to catch some of that
and I thought he did a nice job with all
that the other thing that I thought was
impressive you know was I think their
first six plays of the game were all you
know empty formation stuff no nobody in
the back field which is impressive to
see as a rookie we saw that with Trevor
Simeon that opener against Carolina that
they came out throwing and I granted
he's a second-year player but he's
really a rookie and that impressed me
that you're saying I again you can speak
better to it in quarterbacking
terminology but that confidence level to
say there's nobody in the backfield
everybody knows you're throwing the ball
let's see what you can do yeah you know
I I think there's some positives to that
too is being able to kind of spread
everything out
allows you to see things a little bit
more clearly it just defines things a
little bit easier for you as a
quarterback and so you know I also like
the idea of getting those guys into a
rhythm you know because there's always
you know nerves or whatever that anxious
feeling you know leading into a game and
when you can get those first couple
completions under your belt especially
as a young player is huge Matt joining
us on behalf of play 60 field day with
the NFL pros explain what what's going
to happen yeah it's a it's a pretty cool
partnership between danimals and fuel up
to play 60 they're promoting healthy
lifestyles so healthy nutritious choices
and being active for 60 minutes a day
and as part of this program five lucky
kids across the country are going to
have an opportunity to have an NFL
player come to their school have an
awesome field day get out and move
around and and have a pretty you know
awesome experience and it's really
special for those kids and you know in
order for it to win they've got to look
out for golden bongo ticket kind of like
a willy wonka type promotion and if they
find the golden bongo thing they're
going to have the lucky opportunity to
have an NFL player come to their school
who would who would have freaked you out
if they came to your school when you
were in grade school the quarterback or
play you know like yes brett favre was
my guy when i was young and so if i
would have ever had the opportunity to
kind of meet him at an event like that
where he came out to school I would have
I would have probably been so nervous I
can talk you know and just just kind of
stood there awkwardly and watched well
hopefully you don't stand there and look
awkwardly against the Saints on Monday
night it's always great to catch up with
you man thank you for joining us I
appreciate it damn thank you Matt Ryan
falcons quarterback the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
you